[Music]
what's up I'm Jay Sean and these are my
10 essentials obviously born and raised
in London I live in New York now I had
this passion for music it just it was
just a fascination really with hip-hop
is where it began
I remember watching yo MTV raps and I
was like how do they do that
so I started emulating it I said remind
it was so caught it rewind and learn all
the words I think the charity side of
things for me is very important because
if you're not giving something back
there's an imbalance somewhere not in
your life faster the huge part of my
life when you sharply dressed I think
feel more confident
everybody knows beats by dre right
headphones but not everybody has these
ones these are think one of six I think
they were only handed out to the members
of Cash Money and Young Money so I think
Drake has a pair Nicki Minaj as a pair
I have a pair Netflix this is the only
way that I ever get to watch TV or films
of course Breaking Bad if you don't
watch this there is something wrong with
you and the best thing about Netflix is
of course I watched it all in a day and
a half these are lifesavers for me okay
protein bars again it has to do
traveling I just came back from the
Philippines a show in the Philippines 27
hours door-to-door plain food not doing
it I would rather know what I mean in
what I'm getting out of it so I nibble
on these when I feel like I'm gonna die
oh oh my bad sorry
it's the foampit of any time I got one
of these around into the sleep for me
there's nothing worse for me then when
you get to those fancy hotels with the
fancy thousand duck feathers whatever it
is they're called and you put your head
in it and it just does this around your
head
cologne very important this is one of my
favorites very touch
thought single banner that where that
one sometimes curved it's a good one
hey listen just so you guys know if you
are smelly don't put aftershave or
cologne on top of your sweat and smell
that makes it worse have a shower that's
all you need to do look one of the
things I can't do without accounts its
coffee and you know not just any cup
it's got to be a little fancy club it's
coffee round a little baby in there boom
it's gonna be a tricky part here make
sure I don't spill anything very slowly
very slowly dripping in there I mean
this would be very long if I wait for
that entire coffee to go it's gonna take
ages so I suggest we'll just do a little
cup and then come back when that's ready
and finally we have it this is a toy
that beginning I actually have a real
one
I have a real bambini at home so why I
bought one of these I don't know but I
you know what I can't drive mine I take
this around and I like to do things like
this see this
no even looking see that it's not even
looking
[Music]
so these are just a little selection of
my shoes I can't do without my shoes I
have a very bad problem it's it's an
addiction it's an addiction I have a
four five bedroom house and one of the
bedrooms is dedicated to my shoes
so this do a wonderful Louis Vuitton
watch case is something I cannot leave
home without
so at any one point I have three in here
of which I can choose I think I'm gonna
wear the gold Rolly today again like you
know fitting that with this outfit I
think it will go nicely and I mean I
can't live without this thing I cannot
live without my iPhone I am an app fiend
Hey I think one which is really useful
voice tutor I just have this app and I
go to all my warm-ups before a show so
instead of like having a vocal coach a
real human being poor guy he's our job
okay so I've been Jay Sean thank you so
much for watching my top ten essentials
I hope you guys enjoyed it if you did
make sure that you liked the video or
that good staff comments subscribe and
hashtag GQ ten that's one to zero and
you can follow me on twitter at Jason
follow me on instagram at JCV peace out
[Music]